some of the biggest stars in the world
sign up for the shows set in the
Yellowstone universe but the Dutton Clan
Saga can also make stars out of young
actors including the familiar face who
plays Spencer in 1923.
Yellowstone has proven to be the
franchise that can't be stopped the show
just finished its fifth season and it's
continuing to rack up impressive
viewership numbers plus a slew of
spin-offs are keeping the legend of the
Dutton family alive and well first there
was 1883 which tracked the family's
migration from Texas to Montana by the
time of 1923 the duttons are secure in
their Montana property but there are
various hardships looming 1923 features
several incredible Stars including
Harrison Ford who plays Jacob Dutton and
Helen Mirren who plays Cara Dutton Jacob
and Cara's nephew Spencer Dutton a World
War One veteran who now spends much of
his time tracking big game across Africa
is quickly becoming a fan favorite my
goodness the actor who plays him Brandon
sklanar may not be a household name like
Ford and Miron just yet but he has ample
credits to his name sklanar has mostly
appeared in supporting roles so far
according to IMDb he got his start in
several projects including truth be told
Fallen to me and new girl he finally got
a chance to show his range with a major
part in the 2018 film maplethorpe the
movie follows the life of famed
photographer Robert maplethorpe played
by Matt Smith part way through the film
Robert hires his younger brother Edward
played by sklanar to work as his
assistant while the two seem to get
along at first it's clear there's
tension between them their Dynamic leads
to one of the best scenes in the movie
where the two have a blowout fight and
it's here that's glenar gets to shine I
have this much this much
I need to start my own life in an
interview about the film with the
upcoming at the Tribeca Film Festival he
said it was an incredible experience
yeah I mean it's special material
special story you know Robert was a
special person and it's about art and
love family New York I mean it's
incredible I'm very grateful to be a
part of it sklanar also popped in for
two episodes of HBO's Westworld he
played Henry who in season four went on
an extremely bad date with Evan Rachel
Woods Christina the show's final season
sees Christina working as a video game
writer for Olympiad entertainment when
she goes on her date with Henry he's
pretty much full of himself and can't
even be bothered to remember what it is
Christina does for a living that doesn't
stop him from hitting on her prompting
her to leave in the middle of their
dinner despite the small role a sampling
of redditors found the character
compelling particularly when he hummed
as Christina walked away several
wondered whether Henry was a
fly-controlled human regardless of what
you think it's that attention to detail
that made the show such a hit one
redditor summed it up well writing the
songs and audio of the show have always
been among the best ever made and now
it's part of the storyline before
stepping into the world of 1923 sklanar
could last be seen playing Burt Reynolds
in the offer the limited series told the
story of the making of The Godfather and
in the final episode film producer Al
Ruddy played by Miles Teller brings the
treatment to Reynolds for what would
eventually become the longest yard of
course Reddy finds himself between a
rock and a hard place the studio wants
to capitalize on the success of The
Godfather with a sequel but the producer
is ready to move on throughout the
remainder of the episode Reynolds grows
impatient with Ruddy because he has
other projects on the line but
eventually they find a way to work it
out after mostly supporting roles with
1923 sklanar really gets to step out
front and center here's hoping it's the
first of many Star turns for the actor